[Musique]
c'est une institution calgary
restaurants ou les camionneurs m
s'arrêter quelques minutes avant de
reprendre la route de saint camille est
une habitude le blackfriday ne soit bon
sa ligne mais pour son image pour
montrer qu'il est proche des électeurs
c'est l'endroit idéal parce que c'est le
vrai alberta ils sont des gens sans
prétention les gros bon sens sap est ici
pour se fondre dans le décor le
politicien a même pris le temps de faire
disparaître la cravate qui portait un
peu plus tôt en conférence de presse
car jason kenny ne laisse rien au hasard
j'ai travaillé jusque 5h du matin parce
que la nuit dernière
oui parce qu'il fallut que j'ai prononcé
un discours important et j'ai travaillé
sur le discours que 5,2 matin et vous
êtes levés à quelle heure witter trois
heures de sommeil c'est assez ces bus et
se voit l'homme de 50 ans qui n'a pas
d'enfant et qui a tout dédié à sa
carrière s'est donné une mission ramener
l'alberta dans le giron conservateur
montré que l'élection des néo démocrates
n'était qu'un accident de parcours
son parcours à jason kenny commençons
notariaux les à oakville mais grandit en
saskatchewan
il étudie ensuite en philosophie à san
francisco dans une institution jésuites
sur le campus
il cherche à faire taire les militants
pro-avortement à la fin des années 80 il
déménage à edmonton et prend la tête de
la fédération canadienne des
contribuables déjà à 24 ans c'est un
bourreau de travail
élu député du parti réformiste à
seulement 29 ans il devient l'un des
hommes de confiance de stephen harper
après la fusion de l'alliance et des
progressistes conservateurs au fédéral
il est nommé à plusieurs ministères clés
à l'immigration notamment où il réussit
à rallier plusieurs communautés
culturelles à la famille conservatrice
ont de ces grands faits d'armes
après la victoire de justin trudeau il
quitte la scène fédérale en 2016 et
s'inspire de stephen harper et orchestre
l'union des deux partis de droite en
alberta il premier faux pas dans ce
mariage réussi
une enquête de siby ci a révélé qu'au
moment de la course au leadership du
parti conservateur unis l'équipe de
jason kenny collaborer avec celle d'un
rival pour nuire à son principal
adversaire
j'essaie de kenny parle d'une
collaboration normal imperturbable il
veut contrôler le message de sa campagne
centrée sur l'économie
il l'a même fonds de commerce que
c'était maintenant c'est à dire d'avant
une droite qui veut maîtriser les
budgets des terminaux gouvernement
harper on le voyait comme éteint
de ce qui était plus depuis qu'il est
sur la scène politique albertaine
il doit montrer justement que il n'était
pas déconnecté
donc il doit montrer qu' il est proche
des gens si vous êtes illuminé de
l'alberta est la priorité concrètes là
qu'est ce que vous voulez absolument pas
c'est l'élimination de taxer le carbone
qui est imposé par deux tiers des
albertains
si jason kenny martèle son message
économique il est moins ferme sur des
sujets plus délicats comme l'avortement
et les droits des gays qui divise les
conservateurs l'automne dernier un
membre influent du parti conservateur
unis à comparer le drapeau et de gbt qu
au drapeau nazi
j'essaie caignaert condamner ses propos
mais ne l'a pas expulser la formation
politique il ya 160 membres du parti
conservateur d'albertas de plus grande
part c'est pas mon job de faire la
police des opinions de toutes les
membres d'une partie - c'est mon job
d'exprimer nos valeurs qui sont des
valeurs de respect de tolérance ne pas
expulser parce qu'il sait très bien
aussi que c'est une minorité qui est
agissante à notre parti il a besoin de
toutes les forces conservatrices pour
éviter justement la division du vote
conservateur ou par les garde à
l'intérieur du parti
il fait peser sur sa formation politique
le soupçon comme quake l'espèce d'agenda
caché sur ces questions des cinq emmy
affirme avoir évolué d'ailleurs avec ce
1 2 qui était ministre aussi sous
stephen harper assure n'avoir jamais
entendu son ancien collègue tenir des
propos intolérants chrétiens pratiquants
y a rien d'extraordinaire dans ses
points de vue malgré tout certains
craignent que des voix intolérante
s'élèvent au sein du parti le député
albertain avec fraser a rendu un hommage
émouvant à son fils homosexuel en
chambre
il a quitté le parti jason kenny entre
autres parce que son fils était gay
présente sans blague ou d'un budget
c'est une canine ne s'inquiète pas outre
mesure de ces critiques il sent que
c'est son message économique et moins
les questions morales qui résonne chez
une majorité d'albertains il doit quand
même réussir à contenir les ardeurs de
la droite plus conservatrice
éviter les scandales qui pourrait lui
coûter cher